so Dark Souls 3 has added a bunch of new
refinements that are really good for the
game but of course they're also really
hidden and you shouldn't have to puzzle
them out yourself like I did let me tell
you about them number one is that you
can hold down on the d-pad and you'll be
brought to the first item in your quick
select bar for most people this will be
their healing Estus flask and i
recommend you keep it that way because
man once you discover this mechanic
you'll no longer be like our where the
[ __ ] is my Estes and die while you're
toggling for it it's great there's no
longer a drawback to having 10 items in
your quick select bar for number 2
everyone knows that fashion souls is far
more important than the worthless stats
on your armor for example these gloves
have far better defense poise and
resistances but they show my skinny
hollow elbows and that just won't do so
now the game helps you curate the
perfect fashion all with the press of
the right analog stick at the equipment
screen that's better and at some point
in your journey you're going to take off
that helmet and be like holy [ __ ] I look
like beef jerky well don't worry in Dark
Souls 3 it's almost a good thing to go
hollow so let me explain when you
rescued a character called the OL on the
undead settlement bridge you can bring
him back to your shrine and when you
talk to him there you have the option to
draw out your true strength selecting
this option lets you level up once for
free but there is a hidden catch when
you level up for free at yeol you
receive a dark sigil in the key slot of
your inventory and every time you die
with a dark sigil in your inventory you
receive a point of hollowing in your
Start screen visible here the more
hollowing you get the more you look like
beef jerky the darker your covenant
symbol becomes and the more excited
y'all gets every few points of hollowing
just check back at y'all and he'll let
you level up again getting you another
dark sigil in your inventory giving you
more points of hollowing when you die
and again and again until you level up
five times at yeol and he dies of
excitement in his place yuria appears
and the hollowing quest line continued
I highly highly recommend that you go
down this quest line because in my
opinion it's one of the best ones in the
game however it is very very tricky to
do right so check out my law through
series if you're interested in doing the
quest line we're going to go through it
there if you spend hours curating the
perfect waifu i wouldn't do that but
some people like to do it it's weird
anyway don't worry it's easy to reverse
hollowing just by a purging stone from
urea and you can remove all the
hollowing points and furthermore if you
give a fire keeper soul to the fire
keeper then she'll heal the dark sigils
in your inventory so you won't hollow
again good looks don't come cheap though
so remember that number four is that
it's now way easier to play with your
mates just set a password shared between
you both and all of a sudden you will be
able to be summoned regardless of your
soul level to balance this the game will
scale down the phantom strength to match
the hosts also you can't drop a weapon
for your friend that exceeds his or her
maximum upgraded weapon how cool is this
summoning system though for so long
we've been levelling up characters
alongside our friends and that gets so
tricky and complicated this simplifies
things so much but I'll tell you what I
like more than friends invading people
once you get the red eye orb from ring
finder Leonid use it to invade
indefinitely
I'll explain his quest line in another
video but did you know that the rewards
you get for killing a host now depend on
which covenant you're ian for example if
i invade with the red eye orb and a Sun
burrow metal equipped then I'll get
sunlight medals for killing if you go in
as a red phantom mound maker I'll get a
vertebra shackle for killing and so on
if I invade as anything else I think
though I get a pale tongue which is a
reward for the fingers of Rosaria
covenant which is associated with the
red eye orb so if you want to farm those
three covenant rewards then PvP with a
friend or invade others it's really good
for switching it up additionally the
color of your red phantom now changes
depending on your equipped covenant as
well you can see here I'm this sexy
golden red phantom because I'm a Sun bro
Invader I love the way it looks so yeah
try some Jolly murdering for once
another related thing is to do with
invasion requirements you can only
invade people who match or are below
your maximum upgraded weapon level in
addition to the soul level system also
being in place a user named prin acts on
reddit actually did a great write-up on
the invasion requirements and you should
go and check it out it's really
interesting I'll put it in the
description below number six one thing
that I discovered from watching PvP
streamers was that you can now parry
people even if they attack you from
behind apparently a shield parry now
effects phantoms in a 360 radius around
you but is this a bug or a feature time
will tell the number 7 I've written down
that you can perform visceral attacks on
a ton of enemies
some of whom don't even look stagger
about the head is what you often want to
aim for on many enemy creatures but the
main thing I want to talk about is that
if you hit an enemy regularly during
this time just with the light attack for
example you'll now hear a different
sound which indicates that you're
dealing more damage during their
vulnerable state you also hear this
sound on counter hits and all the other
vulnerable times it's a nice touch
number 8 when you run and press r2 now
you do a jumping attack these can also
be initiated by pressing forward and r2
of course what's also new is that you
can do a rolling attack animation
immediately after a jumping attack I
found for most weapons this is really
good for Crystal lizards because jumping
attacks often fling them onto their back
and rolling attacks are often vertical
or pokes number 9 when you do a jump by
pressing l3 when you're running you no
longer have to do the mandatory roll at
the end of it if you stop pressing
forward on the left analog stick as soon
as you initiate the jump then your
character will come to a standstill like
this this is particularly good for
tricky jumping puzzles like this one but
there really aren't many uses for this
right now at all which is a shame I
never thought that Dark Souls needed
jumping puzzles because the jumping
mechanic has always been trashed but the
fact that this exists that you don't
have to roll is almost like an easter
egg would be interesting if they put a
puzzle
you have to stop the jump you can't do
the roll
in order to get the reward I think that
would be neat all right number 10 using
weapon arts with no focus still works
for a lot of weapons and while their
effectiveness is often reduced some
weapons are worth using simply for their
weapon art for example the sunlight
straight sword has a buff that you can
apply even with a tiny bit of focus and
daggers have a quick step that functions
with no focus at all this is
particularly handy when you're rolling
through the swamp just equip a dagger
and fly through the swamp with the
weapon art instead look at how much
faster this is it brought my swamp
experience up to a almost bearable it's
pretty good the next five secrets are
little quickfire secrets first you can
do a charge attack by holding r2 like in
blood-borne you can also throw some
knives while running and some spells
like Ferrand art while running as well
you get a heavy roll at above 70%
equipped burden so it's very beneficial
to stay below 70% power stance dual
wielding no longer exists in Dark Souls
3 which is sad because I think that was
one of the best things the Dark Souls 2
brought to the table you can now
two-hand dual wield herbal weapons
instead and for number 15 I want you to
go and check out this video it's by a
streamer named Scott jund who did an
awesome little write-up on how defense
works in Dark Souls 3 my favorite
discovery in that video was that having
an empty armor slot is something you
just never want to do and that even
wearing rags in that armor slot can
drastically increase your defence so
subscribe if you want to this channel is
all about Dark Souls so we got stories
and tips and guides and if you have any
other tips throw them in the comments
section it's really fun to be able to
unpack the game with you guys and I'm
sure there's some stuff I've missed and
I hope there is because I don't want
this to end also if you have another
browser tab free open up RB Frosty's
twitch stream and throw him a follow
because he helped a ton with all the
multiplayer testing and he is another
great streamer in the community that you
should support thanks for watching and
supporting me and I'll see you in the
next one for more Dark Souls 3
you